why invest so much time in all those
shorts did you realize that you were
going to work your way up to a feature
eventually oh yeah that was feature
films was always the goal from the
beginning but I've I've always had a
very realistic approach to the industry
like I didn't expect to be able to make
transformers like my first week out you
know what I mean so I always felt like
it was the the craft it was really
important to really study it to
understand it to be a student of film to
take my time and sort of get as
technically skilled as I could through
studying through courses or whatever it
is not not be so much in a rush to sort
of just throw things out there but you
know really have a solid foundation and
really have a great understanding of all
the different aspects of filmmaking so
yeah most of those was really just to
sort of go through the process because
you learned so much going through the
process like it's one thing to have all
these ideas but until you really go
through it and come out the other side
like you really don't understand it
fully you don't really know what it
takes to go from script to screen and
although all those little things
in-between and so I wanted to start from
a place where I would be comfortable to
start small not being the rest to jump
out there and make a feature but really
just focus on like the art and the
techniques of filmmaking and sort of as
you know as I'm comfortable to this sort
of Bright's out and make things bigger
and bigger you know so yeah it was it
was it was always in the cards to make
features but
I wanted to be comfortable before before
I jumped in you know and then ultimately
on my first feature I produced it myself
I didn't ask for any funding at all
because I felt like before I could
expect someone to invest in me I needed
to to show that I invested in myself and
I wanted to show the value of my work
you know because you know that's that's
a big thing asking someone especially
for someone you don't know asking them
to take their hard-earned money and sort
of invest in you and the question just
looking at it from a realistic
standpoint the question would be like
well why why invest in your like can you
even make this film like this thing
you're asking me to give you money for
can you even do it like you know you
have to be able to show that you you're
capable of producing this thing that
you're asking people to pay you to make
and so I wanted to have a track record
of of work and I want a body of work
that they could see basically I want to
take all the knows away like any reason
they would have to say no I wanted to
take that away from them and so a lot of
that has to do with having a track
record having a body of work even if
it's even if you're you haven't had
anything distributed yet it you know you
you haven't had any big successes there
yet to at least have a body of work that
can show consistent growth in like show
the value of what you have to offer you
know I thought it was important so when
you think back to being in Brazil and
then being in South Carolina or
somewhere in the south
how are you choosing which films you
watched when you were younger like who
was influencing you was your dad
I think I think it came from it came
from martial arts and then it then it
came from my love of storytelling you
know a lot of people think I only make
access homes but I I make like every
Ranger film I just happen to love action
movies because you know something I grew
up watching but yeah I think the martial
arts was the biggest influence and but
then also films that had nothing to do
with action I just like really smart
films it really films up thinking man
films you know think films that would
make you think maybe be a little
unpredictable
maybe the approach to telling a story is
unique or you know sometimes it's just
how you present the idea sometimes it's
the way that you go about telling the
story visually you know there's there's
all these different ways of even if you
don't have a lot of money you can still
make something unique you can still do
something interesting and different you
know and I think a lot of times people
get too caught up on the budget and they
start to limit themselves like based on
the budget well you know I don't have
enough money to do this but maybe
there's another way you can approach
that that problem or maybe is another
way you can approach telling the story
that could be unique that maybe it
doesn't cost a lot maybe it's in the way
you shoot it maybe it's in the way you
lied it maybe it's in the way you added
it maybe it's in the sound is on there's
something like that so anytime I create
something I never I never I never
can strain on it based on the dollar
amount you know I try to not think about
that I try to think about in terms of
how can I approach this in an artistic
way or a visually striking way or
something like that
[Music]
you